unmute that works okay hell hello I'm
too loud so I'm going
talk about Face Swap step by step step
by step instruction how to do it it's
gonna be probably crafted work without
any magic like neural networks
convolution and so on so actually
conclusion will be there but without
magic
I also need that ok works so first of
all I need to know if in this room does
a person who didn't have even think
about face detection face swapping
landmarks detection and just came here
because that the topic sounds like it's
lightweight for the light conference day
so is that it's such a person here take
the other experience okay so maybe I
will randomly choose you I know you're
or you work here but you're gonna help
me so imagine that you have two images
not a video the presentation is about
video well that let's imagine you have
images and you want to crop out face
from one picture and paste it into
another you have Photoshop for example
and can you explain what steps can you
take to do that he actually have the
microphone already that's awesome so
let's let's try okay so I will detect
the features like no detection you you
have you have your mouse you have
photoshop you and your mouse okay yeah
no automation you do it by you know but
detection sounds more professional okay
yeah okay so step by step let's say
three steps that's I think that's enough
only face no her no just face okay so I
would provide the frame of the face but
I would also mark some features like
nose eyes and lips I I would stretch I I
would I don't have to do that because I
can stretch that face to fit to another
one to stretch in that way that way
it might look very strange but only one
step would be enough just to mark the
face and then stretch it to fit to
another okay so that's some ideas we
have two pictures you get the face from
the first one let's say you paste it on
the another and just stretch it a little
bit so it fits let's say okay that
sounds good and I that basically our
principle that this is how you'll do it
and we have different minutes so for
achieving different results you can do
as much as you said or we said together
you can do something more and we will do
something more but the principle is the
same for everything so let's start with
the first slide I will introduce myself
right now I'm super sturdy and cozy I'm
a husband I'm a father and I'm Python
developer trust dump in that order
usually and just an information after
this talk I need to just go and run for
my train so if you have any questions
that I won't answer in the Q&A Q&A
session send me an email my github my
LinkedIn that's it and also about trust
hump trust on this us-based our startup
in Atlanta Georgia we're working on no
real customer solutions for banking
industry mostly and we work tightly with
Warsaw software Houston clouds which is
are just across the river where's the
river somewhere there and I actually
came from thin clouds then we were
transferred directly to trust um and we
still have some projects in entangled so
if you want to work for trust important
clause then I can answer the questions
if you want let's start with the agenda
so we're gonna talk about yeah one note
I thought I have 40 minutes but I have
25 so I think I'm gonna speed up a
little bit so we have face detection
found facial onerous detection finding
face border that's important
approximating nonlinear operations
finding triangles for image
transformations from the previous point
blending commanded images together
stabilization video stability stop
Beauty session
okay so let's talk about the goal so you
more or less know what are the mechanics
before behind apps like snapchat you
know how to tackle the problem of
Facebook you know that most of the heavy
lifting is already implemented in dilip
or OpenCV with one exceptional gonna
talk about this and you know why face
whopping face so often and so meta info
just about the talk so I don't see that
because I have a timer I will go here so
the ideas for solutions comes from
mainly from learn open CV calm and by
image search calm blocks if you're
interesting to the topic I encourage you
to go there because there are people
that are passionate about that and they
create awesome stuff on this book so I
recommend you to visit it the second one
is examples are written with open CV
dilip and numpy of course in Python safe
questions for the Q&A session unless you
notice real not true for example and
remember the slide name that gonna speed
up a bit because I said I thought we
have 40 minutes we'll use pictures of
the following stars in the examples
so that's Clint Eastwood Jamie Foxx
Pamela Anderson and Christophe graphic
so first of all face detection histogram
of oriented gradients that's one of the
methods we have other like hard Cascades
and probably even thousands more methods
of detection face sohow histogram of
rented gradient works in a nutshell
you have to know I don't want to go to
details in this presentation I did you
just need to know that feature
descriptor that means we have some image
and out of this image we produce a
feature vector and then this feature
vector is an input to some classifier
for example as VL and that's it
so once we have that classifier trained
we have let's say that that's a picture
of people my audience my audience and I
need to find all the faces in this
picture so what I do is to I look for
these faces using small in this example
square patches and I'm looking forward
just moving step bus that where when the
steps are pretty small and I'm also
using I'm also using a smaller scale I'm
using all of it and I'm trying to find
and all of this of course I forgot to
say that the small patches are producing
hawk or histogram of oriented Grandin's
feature vectors that are then passed to
the classifier classifier returns some
result and then the face is detected
where the result was the highest simple
as it at is it so how to implement that
in Python and delete okay so how to
implement that that's pretty simple
improve delete input import open CV
create maybe I will show here on the
with the mouse you just import the stuff
that we need we create get frontal face
detector object we load an image and we
use detector to
okay so we load the images and the the
return is rectangles they know their
mind mind be known rectangles one
rectangle more rectangles that many
rectangles that are faces in the picture
so so this is how it works actually I
think okay this is how it works and now
let's assume that we are used simple
copy-paste image no not okay doesn't
look good okay let's go further faster
landmark detection so we also use dilip
in this case
Dileep returns for a given image it
returns 68 fashion landmarks and it's
important to understand that every point
has has its own identifier it's unique
for the whole face it's important to
understand because if you detect lonna
marks on my face and i will try on your
face you have the same number for
example in the left corner of the right
eye which is 43 i guess so we would have
the same identifiers and this is pretty
important to understand briefly how it
works so in the leap implementation uses
one millisecond phase alignment paper in
a nut so oh yeah what is it called phase
alignment not face detection so in fact
it's a phase alignment because in the
first iteration of the algorithm as you
can see t0 we have some general facial
points on the face and then after each
iteration t equals 10 we have it's so
close to the ground true that we can
stop iterating further and that means
this is why we call it phase alignment
not detection we align general face to
the real shape of on the image in the
image right and this is how to implement
it it's pretty straightforward we just
add this predictor we load shape
predictor 68 face landmark model I think
the size is up around 100 megabytes this
is why it's it takes so long to learn
the program so we detect faces and we
pick the biggest face justice amplify
you can get first place for example if
you want I just I'm thinking the biggest
and you pass it to the predictor with
with an image and rectangle in which the
face was detected and the results is the
68 landmarks that we
oh yeah and how it works okay next next
thing that we need is to find the border
of the face and we use convex who to do
it what's convex who so convex who is
for a given set of points convex hull is
a subset of this points such subset that
the rest of the points is inside this
subset just like on the picture and some
may ask what's the difference between
convex school and contour and does the
difference greenish contour and red this
convex hull so the difference is that
it's convex that's why and it's pretty
simple to any parent to you pass the the
landmarks that we detect that we need to
change the structure a bit don't worry
about that and we pass it to the convex
hull function with return points to
false and that means that I don't get
the location of the points in return I'm
getting the indexes that we are talking
about in our faces that's pretty
important stuff to understand oh yeah
how it works so my face border will be
in blue actually my mask I would say
yes so getting pretty close to see some
results and yeah
the next thing approximating nonlinear
operations with linear ones first of all
what's doing an operation fine
transformation for example so in a
nutshell that means when you have a line
and you do the president the
transformation after the transformation
this line is still aligned or if you
have parallel lines after transformation
they are two so that's that's an example
on the grid and that's an example in
real life I just shared it a bit like
skewed in in [ __ ] so this is how it
looks
and what's nonlinear transform it's the
opposite so the line it's not the line
anymore it's curved and that's basically
how you need to do this the so-called
stretching that you set about right so
the face is not flat as Pamela was on my
face in the first example but it's
rather feed better to my face shape okay
and that's an example does that's a fish
eye effect I think that's that's this is
how it's called and why we're talking
about this because that's pretty common
in computer graphics that we approximate
complex objects with triangles that's
pretty common and we have an example of
some complicated montains shape and it's
approximated perfectly with triangles
unfortunately because it's so popular it
doesn't have its own implementation
though in OpenCV so you have to create
your own one and I'm gonna skip this I
just I just want to say yeah I just want
to say that there's Satya Malik the guy
from learn OpenCV dot-com and he
implemented that so you can just go
there and see basically that means you
cannot get one triangle and transform it
into another you have to do it with the
whole picture so that's the whole you
have to play with this cropping this
rectangular shapes then you have to use
the mask to
only apply it for the triangle not the
whole picture and so on and so on so
basically you need to implement it by
itself or use the Satya Malik's
implementation so this is how it works
with oh yeah maybe maybe one example how
it what I mean by transforming triangle
so that's a simple picture of ten clouds
like from for yield forever years ago
and there's a green triangle and we're
going to transform it into another
jungle this jungle so this is not a
random triangle please pay attention to
this circle here so it's not it's not
looking like a circle right now maybe
more like ellipse I don't know so
basically does the idea behind warping
triangles and that's how the example
works right now
okay so we need to find this triangle
first so one of the methods I think that
they are more but one of the methods to
do it it's the Loon triangulation and
what does it mean it's just the lunar
angulation just sup subdivide the space
or the surface into triangles in such
way that if you look at any triangle on
the image like for example this one and
you look at the circum circle around it
there is no other point that it's inside
the circle Circle Circle Circle Circle
right and this is one of the methods to
how to divide the space and this is how
to implement that so I who is my face
border as you remember I also added face
points so you can see my teeth and then
we just we create sub div to the object
we insert all these points that I
created or all detected and then I get
triangles just get two angles list and I
have the strangles okay how it works
so it's worth to say that I do that
triangulation only once on the first
frame later I used the same triangles
for every frame that's important okay so
a little wrap-up to make sure that you
understand so taking some triangles and
taking some points and then we have some
transformations so the first the first
step is to get some points in my cases
face border at Mouse points specific
indexes that I added manually then find
strangle de Luna de Lune triangulation
for the first image find corresponding
triangles on the second image
corresponding to the same as on the
first image transform every triangle
from the first image to the second image
and this is how the works in examples
that's my face with points on it
that's convex whoo sorry that's
translation for my face that's the
second picture with points that's the
same triangulation and this is what I'm
talking about when I say that I
transform the same triangle right and
that's that that give us this more or
less 3d effect okay
so as you can see on the example we have
different color of the skin there is
also a way to fix it okay so let's try
to fix it that's also a complicated idea
so you just say in a nutshell how it
works so there is a term called pass on
edit image editing that's a paper for
that there's a link below so the basic
idea is that you don't copy the
identities or the values of the pixels
you copy the gradients it sounds simple
it's much more complicated because it
includes some calculus as you can see in
the in the equation but let's do not
talk about that the simple idea is to
copy gradients instead of Italian cities
and this is an example I just pick a
random picture from the internet with
tattoo and I need to create a mask for
it so I'm gonna take this this region
for my mask and this is how the max mask
looks and I'm gonna paste it on my face
in random places oops
so that's my face with some random data
from the internet as you can see it's
not perfect maybe when I work harder
with the mask it will look better but I
didn't have time yesterday and as you
can see on the my left cheek it looks
quite awesome and on my left shoulder
it's also awesome on the wall is worse
but as you can see right now maybe after
the cold example it it's quite good so
this is how to implement that so there
is a three lines about creating masks so
this is how you create a mask
never mind the the most important thing
to know is that to use similar scrolling
in open CV you need to have source
destination source image destination
destination image mask
Center center which is basically the
place where you want to place the cloned
area and you have to pass the the method
that you use for coin so there are two
methods is mixed clone and it's normal
cloning I in this example I use mix comb
so that's mixed clone
I think normal cloning is not much
different so let's take a look how it
looks like because that's that's pretty
interesting because the the color is
different really let's try with somebody
else for example first of krafchick
better isn't take a closer look it's
shaking right so there is a problem we
want to fix but let's switch to the
first example first the second action
okay and please take a closer look again
it's also shaky you're right
so we want to fix it I but I'm showing
that example because I need to tell you
that that's the problem with the face
landmarks estimation not with the
algorithm that I use later that's the
problem already here so and that's
because every detection is based on the
single image we don't have information
about the previous frames and to fix it
we actually have to get this information
somehow and use it so that's what I'm
going to present right now stabilization
so I recently so after 2 hour session
with my son convincing him to go to
sleep
me and my wife decided to watch some
movie and was few days ago and that was
gangster squad and we decided to watch
it even I was pretty the hosted so never
mind that's the scene and I decided to
put it into this presentation because
this guy tells a true about the optical
fall so he said don't shoot where it's
at shoot to where it's going and that's
basically all about optical flow where a
predator like no lion is chasing it's
its victim it also uses optical flow it
tries to predict where it's going to be
in a second I don't know in two seconds
maybe based on where is it now and
velocity and that's basically how
optical flow works it tries to predict
future position of a point so that's
going to be end in a knot so of course
so that's the only equation that optical
flow has its UV that's the next position
of points and that's some difference
between X by the time some difference in
Y's
and there is a problem it's unsolvable
because we have two unknowns U and V and
we have only one equation so we need
some assumptions to make it work the
first assumption is brightness constancy
assumption it basically means that the
same point in every frame has the same
brightness which actually makes sense
because more or less that's true so
that's the assumption so it can be weak
why not but and that equation says that
but it actually didn't get we didn't get
any new equation so we have to use some
more advanced assumption which is there
are a few of them but we use lucas
kannada method which is that the flow is
essentially constant in a local
neighborhood of the pixel under
consideration in human language it means
if we have this point red point in the
in the center we assume that all the
points around let's say in this example
is three on three pixels we assume that
all of them have the same optical flow
and thanks to that assumption we have
nine equations and only two unknowns
this is pretty easy to solve and using
this assumption optical flow works so
this is how to implement that so as I
said you need to have you need to have
the previous position of of an image
actually the gray version of it so for
some reason you need the current frame
you need to have previous points from
the previous frame I mean to have
current points from the disk from this
frame and based on that you can have the
prediction of the next points as I said
just a second ago it's a prediction so
we need to combine this information to
just to this points to run smoothly not
just shaking around just as a husband so
so we want to combine this information
so the the actual point is a combination
of landmark detected landmark and the
predicted lumber
and I just choose 30% versus 70 percent
because because that worked okay let's
let's check how it works
let's drive okay it's not anymore but
it's largely right now so that's the
trade-off but there is a solution for
that
I didn't implement that because I didn't
have time you can for example make it
dependent you can you can have the 0 3 &
0 7 dependent on the velocity of the
points because as you can so in the
example the faster I'm moving the faster
sorry the more lugging the the optical
flow is so you can make it dependent on
the velocity no problem using some
function ok I think that's the summary
so you know the basic steps for the face
whap right now I hope so does the face
detection animal detection warping
triangles a seamless cloning optical
flow you more or less know how these
methods works work in general you have
the basic idea if they are hard or not
to implement in Python except for this
triangle VAR but I I promise you it's
done by Satya Malik already ok and
that's it any questions so the question
was why I just didn't use a simple
moving average actually right yes you
can do it I didn't because I wanted to
show that optical flow such complicated
machinery is already implemented in
OpenCV and we have that for free yes so
the basic idea is to use for example
let's use the positions of the points
from the last 5 frames and use the use
the average of them for the next point
or the weighted average so the closer
you are to the last prediction like we
are in the current frame so that this
frame is it has higher wave weight and
this frame a little bit lower and so and
so on so yeah that's that's also an idea
as I said we have some principles to
make it work but we have many many
methods to actually make it work so
that's another one any more questions
because we have minus three seconds four
five I don't think so I think that maybe
the deep phase have some it doesn't work
that way deep way is different I'm not
talking about porn industry and talking
about making for example putting saying
words that he didn't say that's
threatening right and I think it works
better than than this that solution so I
don't think I know any except for
entertainment any more questions
I don't see any hands rise so thank you
very much oh yeah
all the code that I use is on this
address you can just go to my github and
there is a face for proposal story and
all of these examples are there if
you're interested how its implemented
and you can use it on your machine if
you want thank you